Фінляндія - північний сусід Росії, з якою у фінів традиційно дуже непрості відносини.
І от у рамках переговорного марафону щодо врегулювання кризи на українсько-російському кордоні
виникла дискусія щодо так званої "фінляндизації" України.
Цим терміном описують ситуацію, коли країна потрапляє під вплив більш могутнього сусіда,
хоча зберігає суверенітет і свою політичну систему.
Аркадій Мошес, директор дослідницької програми з європейського сусідства ЄС та Росії Фінського інституту міжнародних відносин
вважає проведення таких історичних паралелей некоректним.
Почнемо з того, що цей досвід не був вибором Фінляндії.
"Фінляндизація" була на той момент для Фінляндії єдиним доступним їй способом,
погодившись на обмеження суверенітету, зберегти внутрішній устрій країни.
На думку експерта, ті, хто зараз вживає поняття "фінляндизація", не зовсім розуміють її основ та наслідків.
Згідно з публікаціями американських та французьких видань, президент Франції Еммануель Макрон
ужив цей термін під час візиту до Москви як одну з можливих моделей для розрядки напруги з Росією.
Газета New York Times написала, що "фінляндизація" України є частиною дипломатичного дискурсу.
Однак під час візиту до Києва Макрон запевнив, що не використовував цей термін.
Я скажу, що дуже добре, що Макрону довелося виправдовуватися та заперечувати сам факт.
Що він міг використовувати ці слова.
Тепер, можливо, використання цих слів, цієї термінології стане трохи менше.
Тому що, на жаль, величезна кількість європейських політиків, особливо у Німеччині та Франції,
дуже люблять говорити про "фінляндизацію".
Врешті-решт колись цьому треба покласти край.
Експертка з Брюсселя Тереза Фаллон також вважає концепцію так званої "фінляндизації" для України неприйнятною
та звернула увагу на те, що і Макрон, і Зеленський від неї відмовилися.
Це майже принизливе вираження спроби поставити Україну на якийсь шлях.
Можливо, вони й обговорювали це, але я думаю, що у громадській площині це надзвичайно чутлива тема.
У тому числі й через вісім років війни та 14 тисяч загиблих в Україні.
Це фактично зробило Україну прозахіднішою.
Отже, ця ідея "фінляндизації", ймовірно, вже віджила своє.
Повертаючись до Фінляндії, слід зазначити, що країна досі не є членом НАТО.
Але тісно співпрацює з Альянсом.
Президент Фінляндії на тлі дипломатичної напруги заявив, що вимоги Росії про гарантії безпеки
і нерозширення НАТО суперечать порядку забезпечення європейської безпеки, що склався,
і зачіпають інтереси фінів.
Фінляндія зберігає за собою право будь-якої миті, не питаючи ні в кого дозволу,
подати заявку на вступ до Північноатлантичного альянсу,
повідомила пізніше фінська прем'єр-міністерка.
Звісно, Фінляндія сама ухвалює рішення щодо зовнішньої політики та безпеки.
Ніхто не може вплинути на нас: ані США, ані Росія, ані хтось інший.
Ми самі прийматимемо рішення, як і раніше.
Гострої загрози для Фінляндії нині немає, але ситуація в Україні дуже занепокійлива.
І якщо Росія активізує свої військові дії, я думаю, що ми повинні підготувати дуже рішучі дії також з боку ЄС.
А що думають західні експерти щодо пропозиції "нейтрального статусу" для України,
аби задовольнити вимоги безпеки Росії?
Це одна з можливих тез із переговорного закулісся.
Але чи погодиться на це українська громадськість?
Крім того, це також означало б тривожний меседж як для Швеції, так і для Фінляндії,
оскільки вони побоюються, що двері до НАТО можуть закритися.
Їхній статус нині нейтральний. І багато аналітиків стверджують, що якщо нині задовольнити вимоги Путіна,
то він попросить ще більше гарантій в регіоні.
А на думку Аркадія Мошеса із Фінського інституту міжнародних відносин,
поняття "нейтральний статус" у буквальному значенні цього слова також втратило актуальність у сучасній Європі.
Поняття нейтральності або нейтралітету в Європі вже практично не існує.
Можливо, Швейцарія ще може вважатися нейтральною країною.
Усі країни, які входять у Європейський Союз, не є нейтральними країнами,
бо у них є певні положення відповідних угод, які забезпечують військово-політичну співпрацю у рамках ЄС.
Можна говорити про неприєднання, військову позаблоковість тощо,
але це кожна країна повинна вирішувати для себе.
Експерт вважає, що в період "фінляндизації" країна не могла сама зробити свій зовнішньополітичний вибір,
і тому говорити в 21 столітті про обмеження країн у їхньому праві вибору абсолютно неприйнятно.